[Music]
in gone too soon news
submitted by I'm show rapper Mac Miller
has died I'm an apparent overdose oh
yeah P that's crazy yeah and then he's
at what he died at 26 26
that's like Jimi Hendrix Amy Winehouse
like all of them right oh well that was
at all 27 here's a photo of Mac Miller
in case you don't know who he is he was
hella talented was a nice tattoos I've
never seen more people during the death
of somebody who acted like he was their
friend yeah see all that yeah it's
pretty weird everyone has a picture of
him
maybe it was just a friendly guy yeah
maybe they were really friends maybe you
made Oh cuz he was kind of underground
for a while so I was like oh like you
know like pictures with atmosphere I'm
like where were your pictures last week
dawg
how come Union post his picture until he
died well like let's say if Tim died I
think you would have so many people
posted him cuz he's friends there yeah
yeah and he does tours and stuff I only
got like five friends so no one really
posted me I'm just looking for a home I
get it but some people are really
friendly yeah that's true I didn't
listen to him for a while
Matt melius norco he was born in a
Pittsburgh that's so sad man he's so
young he died in San Fernando Valley
there's another fentanyl one right come
sing confirm that it was an overdose so
initially they were reporting there was
an overdose they deferred his cause of
death so they still don't know they
don't know does that mean like his
family members like don't want to do it
or other just still like doing know so
the medical examiner is still trying to
figure out they can't figure it out
because they're saying that when they
went to the scene that there was nothing
that immediately said like oh this is
why he died and his in his brother I was
saying like he wasn't depressed or like
all these people were saying like yeah
man he you committed suicide cause he's
the press and they're trying to make it
into that in his bones like nah man he's
he was fine like yeah because the media
was reporting that
his drug addiction stuff got worse after
they he broke up with Ariana Grande
that's uh they were trying to make oh
yeah they always do that trying to [ __ ]
up his image find some narrative thing
that they can pay homage to because she
had to disable her comments on her
Instagram because people immediately
were blaming her how annoying is that uh
like instead of blaming so so let's say
and r.i.p cuz Mac Miller was dope but um
instead of saying like he's a grown man
making his own decisions they go and
they blame her yeah like what would she
have that's like that's like me
overdosing and they immediately and I
die and they blame you for even though
it's true that you give me like a lot of
stress and you yeah but that's that's
still [ __ ] up for them to publicly do
that I would just think that's very you
liar you probably didn't even effect to
use I'd be like nobody stresses do down
more than geo on NGOs on G and on jakey
absolutely because ariana grande's
probably morning to she's probably bad
so what's that X just it's not like they
didn't have memories together you know
like she tried to get him sober like she
tried to get him help
it's it's like it's the [ __ ] media
man like when they try to make drama job
and people to click and all that
[ __ ] just so you know they're just
[ __ ] with perception you know what's
funny so do you guys know who Brittany
Furlan is yeah okay so she's dating
Tommy Lee oh yeah lucky girl yeah so so
this was [ __ ] funny because she
basically told the media in like didn't
even purposely do this so at the hotel
that they were vacationing at someone
was about to get married so they had all
the wedding stuff prepared she's not
part of that wedding she just so
happened to stumble across it so her and
Tommy were just kissing under the thing
and she's in her robe and so is he but
then the media got wind of that caught
wind of that and they just started
saying that they like eloped and they
just got married like under the radar
and it was just a very small intimate
wedding for just friends and family they
made up stories yeah and she just kept
pulling
reposting this she's like I never even
mentioned that like all that says was
like just kissing my honey or something
like that and like like every single new
source was like they got married like it
was hush-hush and if they pulled in all
these little details like it was just
friends and family and she was just like
what the [ __ ] that's crazy
so damaging like when new sources [ __ ]
up [ __ ] like this and destroy the
perception for people like yeah and in
like misinformation right there's got to
be some type of like and they don't
handle t they don't issue an apology or
corrector like a little asterisk
correction at the bottom so deleted that
week how about that [ __ ] it's like they
get something wrong and then they just
delete their tweet about it it's like
dude what happened over cuz we actually
got a lot of fake news before and now we
have to go on Snopes and we have to
double-check and make sure that it's
actually like real news because we'll go
to real sources and get some [ __ ] wrong
and then on the blaming [ __ ] where
people blame like our Ganga Arianna
Grande I remember do you guys remember
when Tony Romo played for the Cowboys
yeah he had a was having a bad season so
they blamed it on just at the same time
he was dating Jessica Simpson so they
blamed it on her so they were all
blaming Jessica Simpson because the
Cowboys thought it was just like yo so
because he's dating a public figure not
when he's dating like some random girl
named Sarah nobody cares about that
because nobody knows random girl named
Sarah yeah but because they can go oh
that's Jessica Simpson everyone's like
holy [ __ ] Jessica sense is ruining the
cowboys and cowboys fans were [ __ ]
pissed because the media looks dope that
up but that's not be so funny if if the
media goes random girlfriend Sarah has
been has been arguing that and they've
been arguing neighbors claim that
they're all throughout the night they're
yelling wouldn't it be me like when
Philip Rivers has a bad game they're not
like where's his wife
where's his wife where's his seven
children his seven kids you know I mean
literally maybe seven kids keeping them
up at night that's more real that's way
real that's an actual real narrative
that's potentially affecting the charges
play and maybe has been affecting them
for a long having a celebrity girlfriend
night he's killing it fantasy but the
tea man who boy there did
unlucky steaming Hannah Ferris me what
the tickets are really cheap though if
you want to go to a game so maybe
Packers can play them and I forego some
cheapest that's true so what's going on
with Ariana like is she just like under
the [ __ ] like microscope of people
and then being burnt and [ __ ] and people
hate her yeah pretty much [ __ ]
that's why she had to disable her
comment that's [ __ ] that she just went
through the [ __ ] preacher groping her
and then this now what some [ __ ]
remember the bombing in her concert
remember what she looked at donut yeah
we should look at I think it is her
fault that the preacher groped her to
you though cuz she was just you know she
[ __ ] over Mac Miller before you used
to be really funny now you just go to
like [ __ ] crazy town and you don't
bring anyone so any one of us along
complete the thought maybe maybe can you
back him up and he's not funny maybe
he's got it maybe he's I think he's
funny
he just has to set it up because people
don't know if he's serious she has been
she's been stressing him out at home and
that's why Bart's not too much time at
the gym too much time with Geo and then
he has a kid now Ilana no no it's the
wife it's the way well yet pride you oh
it's the way it usually is well she's
the most famous one like who's next to
him so that's gotta be her so funny
until Gio married him and had a baby
[ __ ] the comedy got destroyed I think
you're right that's probably where it
was man what do I do
should I disable what do I just disable
your disable your comments now Wow right
away in this video do it now so that
yeah you still like Gio until she ruined
the parts comedy yeah I like your photo
and you're right see what you get to you
for calling fart out you could've just
let him complete his thought but no now
you were gonna ruin your career guys are
we are we still playing are we really
bullying me right now
now bowling was last month's trending
topic now it's how wives are learning
husband Bart can be funny again then
we'll know that you guys that you're
doing good at home yeah yeah okay so we
stick to it so we're am I still make in
front of me yeah stupid people who think
it's yeah okay so what do I do what I do
you know disable comments and hide be a
good victim yeah okay but yes so anyway
so Ariana and I clearly dated for about
two years and then after they broke up
in April like shortly after that's when
she got engaged with Pete Davidson and
then like that's why everything it's
like going towards her like oh my god
you drove him over these she can't even
enjoy her engagement I know I [ __ ]
sucked
man I like Mac Miller though but like
just mean for like all the people to go
after ariana I was hearing there was
fentanyl laced with his thing but I
guess that's unclear now I haven't girl
the last that I heard it was just that
they need more time to investigate so
originally it was uh it was like
declared overdose on what drug did they
say okay because I know I remember the
overdose thing happening like that was
the that was what was circulating and
then people were claiming like he
committed suicide because he was
depressed and all this stuff and I'm
just like man that's so weird I mean
even if that was the truth like he he
was really depressed and he's been
hiding it because you know some of the
most happiest people are actually the
most depressed - right
so that could be the case there is an
issue in in just like entertainment in
general of how many people like just
self-destruct and that isn't really
talked about like a lot like a lot of
people that seem like they're in the
highest point in their lives
sometimes just self-destruct and that
shit's like how common is that is that
something that's just like stands out
because you know it's pretty crazy or is
it really common into industry I mean
artists also just like feel so much more
you know that's true feel so much more
I'm a sensitive as [ __ ] yeah I think
feels so much bigger than they maybe are
I can actually
and you just kind of spiral them and you
have a good imagination and so should
just kind of conspire all and you feel
everything and I just think the drama
actually is that big too so if you're
Ariana right and you're just trying to
have a normal relationship with this new
person and out of nowhere
you have to private all your comments
because people are blowing you the [ __ ]
up you're like what the [ __ ] I'm a
normal person too
trying to live my life but like Brittany
Furlan like everyone's just trying to
take whatever thing they're doing and
twisting it all up and throwing it back
at them that's almost that's a lot of
drama to deal with dude I see us on
YouTube all the time to were because I
we know a lot of these people personally
and then we'll see like some public
spatters some people got divorced or
whatever the because he's gay because he
was cheating on her because of thing oh
I saw in this vlog here he was hanging
out with this girl and it's like why did
he leave it in the footage then you
[ __ ] idiot like you doesn't really
think that he's that these people are
like cheating or whatever and they're
leaving evidence and their vlogs it's
crazy
guys is cheating one more time today
just you know from my new subscribers I
don't know that I cheat all the time
yeah or even in duty in these videos
people think that were actually pissing
each other we were like like just now
but you know yeah that was real you guys
know there are people that take
advantage of that like the Kardashians
who are masters yeah of dating that type
of emotion same with Trump like he's a
master of getting people riled up and
then gaining free publicity I was
reading this study though that like
people like people don't like gaps in
their brain like subconsciously you
don't want to have a gap so you yeah you
subconsciously fill the gaps yes their
fault they have so many can't want to
fill the gaps too what could you want
everything to make sense exactly yeah
so they build their own narrative if
there wasn't one if there isn't like a
solid one like story that they got then
they just start building it because
people aren't trained detectives so they
don't know how to duck they just don't
have a [ __ ] life and worried about
their own [ __ ] I like having jobs in my
brain I don't want to tie all these
crazy things it's like you're constantly
being of conspiracies and they don't
even need to be there so you just have
big old gaps there yeah good guys I just
go okay this happened that happened cool
what about like liking musicians for
their music instead of their life yeah
yeah it's weird how that works like like
do I love cuz I love Denzel Washington
it's like but do I want to know who
Denzel Washington is do I try to watch
the interviews where I find out about
Denzel Washington no I kind of liked the
mystery I don't know why yeah I don't go
ooh he he got [ __ ] up for [ __ ] not
paying taxes he's going to jail and you
know like I don't care about what I do
like though you know that one YouTube
channel hot ones or whatever where they
eat like that uh oh yeah yeah the spicy
I do like seeing all the people that are
on mystery eat something spicy yeah yeah
they are their most vulnerable on eat
like some [ __ ] habanero challenge I'd
be tired yeah just to see what I see
pencil walkthroughs doing a habanero
today I would love that video yeah
[Music]